so there weren't really any huge
exclusives for Vita this year and I
think maybe this one was also a little
bit easier for us to decide velocity 2x
really won over everybody for the Vita
category I mean I don't agree that there
were a lot of big data exclusive there
are a lot of Vita only games like
danganronpa and olly olly I think only
came out in the beginning for ps4 and
Vita but velocity 2x I think as far as
gameplay is concerned is a probably the
most like mechanically perfect game is
on the beater right now the whole the
whole game is a tutorial like every
level you're introduced to a new
mechanic can you have to navigate that
level with that mechanic and it's new
for every level and the challenge is
going back and trying to get a perfect
run and once you get to that point where
you can play the game and you know how
to do everything it's so much harder to
get that perfect run in the earlier
levels than it is to say complete a
later level on an imperfect run so that
challenge is just constantly there and I
think that's what makes it so great it's
got a great mix of two different
gameplay mechanics as well like the
side-scrolling zar like you know you're
trying to like speed run these little
levels and like you have these little
twitch action mechanics then it has the
top down and smut stuff which I really
like it's not as like crazy as your
typical like bullet hell game which is
totally fine i don't think you need to
have a million bullets to do all this
stuff and part of the reason it's so
good is because you kind of have to you
have to collect these little items while
you're doing it and it's auto-scrolling
right so you only have like these little
opportunities to get stuff that was what
I think really got me is that sense to
sort of like get everything get perfect
you know just be the best I can be at
this game and it helps it as beautiful
as well like it's got a great color
palette which on the Vita on that screen
is is great to see
it is the best-looking handheld system
out there I mean it is portable system
and when you get a game by velocity that
really shows that off it's just really
nice to look at like that's the kind of
thing you can show your friends ago like
it's maybe this is a reason to pick up a
beautiful you can speak employable I
think the velocity is you know a great
example of a great portable title
because all levels are really short so
you can you know if you're traveling
just knock off one or two levels and
then sort of leave it behind and just
you know like the the actual sort of
layout of the Vita as well i think
really suits this thing being able to
look across when you need to into those
special areas and velocity so you know
it wasn't a poorer cousin I want to say
of like the ps4 million i think it was
like you know who's perfect for this
console